well under the Rousseff occation of
America Department do you know where
snowflakes come from helicopters
helicopters cause snowflakes if you
didn't know New York Times reporting
this as Millennials grow into their
working years with many of them coming
of age in the daunting job market that
followed the Great Recession parents are
more likely to feel a proprietary stake
in their children's careers the hovering
is abetted by a full complement of
real-time communication options from
texting to Skype and social media and
fueled by the desire to see return on
investment for sending their children to
college mom and dad footed the bill made
sacrifices now they want to make sure
they get a mirror as they get a job
where Annie Britton a recruiter with the
office team a division of Robert Half
said she never saw or heard from parents
when she entered the business nearly two
decades ago but has increasingly felt
their influence she recalled a father
calling her in the past two years in an
attempt to get his son an accounting job
the father sent in the resume scheduled
the interview and to her surprise turned
up with him in person at the interview
he was shepherding that thing she said
what's that thing his son the son is
called that thing when office team
solicited employers helicopter parenting
stories in a recent survey they found
that it was not unheard of one told a
job candidate who piped his mother into
an interview via Skype while another
recalled a mother asking if she could
sit in sit for an interview in place of
her child who had a scheduling conflict
a third mother interrupted in the middle
of an interview to ask if she could
observe while search parents may be
outliers and most Millennials are
perfectly capable of negotiating their
way in the workplace some organizations
generally appear to be struggling with
parental meddling former Stanford
freshman Dean claims the report reports
that officials at teach for
erricka have been mystified in recent
years by the volume of parents who
intervene on behalf of their adult
children who the Group employs as
teachers a Teach for America
administrator told that parents had
called him with complaints about such
issues as their child being disciplined
by a principal or having a run-in with a
fellow teacher as though the adult child
were a student in 2007 the collegiate
Employment Research Institute at
Michigan State University published a
survey of seven and twenty five
employers that found that nearly a
quarter had encountered parental
involvement in the hiring thirty percent
reported parents submitting resume for
their children fifteen percent reported
fielding complaints from a parent after
the company didn't hire the child and
nearly ten percent said parents had
insinuate insinuated themselves into
salary and in services what that should
be into salary and benefit negotiations
Wow see I think yeah I got a whole bunch
of Millennials working on our team but I
guess probably fifty sixty percent so I
probably got three or four hundred of
them in the building and I find
Millennials to be phenomenal team
members and they're very easy to
interview because there's only two kinds
of Millennials awesome and on fire and
sucks and they pretty much tell you in
the interview which one they are like in
the first thirty minutes it doesn't take
a lot you don't have to have like some
sophisticated test you've either got an
entitled Rousseff ID little snowflake or
you've got somebody who's on fire to
change the world and bright and driven
and work ethic and everything else and I
love them I got a I got a building full
of them I mean my kids are Millennials
they work here and they're on fire man
and they work their tails off and they
believe in excellence and those are all
over the place so I got to tell you I
haven't asked my HR guys if we've run
into this because it just well they
wouldn't even have brought it up because
if a parent was anywhere near the
interview of a 27-year
twenty-six-year-old they came into
interview here well that's over next you
got fired right then you never even got
a shot because your mummy got involved
you [ __ ]
so really unbelievable you parents you
know we have this is how you create a
whole woosah fication of america here
mommy is involved when her 28 year old
daughter is teaching in a school and the
principal says you're not doing a good
job and gives them professional
professional input and discipline and
you know Teach for America says that the
administrators are getting hounded by
the parents unbelievable by the way if
you're a millennial of substance and I
know that you're out there like I said I
believe in you I got a bunch of you
working here and your parents are doing
that smack them into next week let them
know mommy you have got it like freakin
mind your own business
hello now you know you can be you can be
kind about it the first couple times but
I've watched my kids do this now I'm
pretty good believe it or not about not
interfering because once they're grown I
was kind of like you're grown you know
I'm like that dad you know you're fly
little Eagle fly and if you can ask my
advice but now we're like you know we're
peers now we're friends now but Sharon
she still wants to get involved and tell
them how to do stuff like how to raise
the grandkids the GRANDMONT on the kid
how to raise the grandkid oh my god can
you imagine but the kids just look after
your mom that's your problem
I mean they're nice to her they're
respectful of their mother which is nice
but should they they said good strong
boundaries and so you Millennials that's
what you got to do is you gotta set good
strong boundaries and go now not your
problem mom dad you've got to be kidding
came a parent comes to an interview with
a 25 or a 30 year old person for a job
and we wonder why there's trouble
yeah unbelievable that's a dumbest thing
I've ever heard in my life and like the
parents want to make sure they get a
return on investment no that's not it
they're still parenting that's all it is
they're just just completely have raised
spineless little jellyfish and they have
to go do everything for them or so they
think
so I guess there's two possibilities one
is the little millennial that's in there
is a spineless jellyfish snowflake and
it's not worth the you know not worth a
flip or they're a legitimate on fire
cool millennial like I'm talking about
and they just hadn't set good boundaries
with their parents should be one of the
two right and I got to tell you I can't
imagine I want to my millennial kids
would go off on one of us sure I I mean
they wouldn't be disrespectful they
they're not that way but there's no
possible way that they would let us get
involved in that because it takes their
dignity away unbelievable and you kid is
nope oh geez
can I believe this stuff and well you
know you see the statistics and I'm
living in the basement it goes right
with it it's the same number about 30%
of men males or not men look at 29 years
old still living in Mama's basement good
boy this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]